just being with patients if a patient
comes in with smallpox and in smallpox a
lot of people I don't know if I did I
send you a picture of smallpox Jamie a
lot of people think oh it's it's like
chickenpox like it's not like chickenpox
it's it's a really awful disease and
it's the only disease that we have
eradicated ever in human history yeah
which is incredible so it's it's one of
those ones the other
yeah it's unbelievably terrific versus
children with it it's just and it was so
common it was very common it was it was
very feared as well because it was so
disfiguring and so know if you were for
instance a wealthy woman and you got
smallpox and you were scarred your
family might worry that they couldn't
marry you off so you know it was one of
those diseases that left its mark on you
literally and and it also had a high
mortality rate as well but it wasn't
like chicken pox no there's my my PSA
it's not like chicken pox well it's you
know it's one of those things that we're
so thankful that people figured out how
to get rid of something yeah and and on
in smallpox vaccine was invented in 18th
century most people don't know it's it's
that old that's terrible yeah Edward
Jenner invented it and actually the
biggest anti-vaxxer movement or protest
happened in 19th century hundred
thousand people turned out to march in
Britain against Jenner people thought
that their children would turn into cows
because he used cow pox the virus cow
pox to bestow immunity onto people and
so there was this huge fear that you
know it was dirty to kind of insert this
animal virus into people and so there's
this big protest a hundred thousand
people to protest the fact that six
parents had been jailed for not
vaccinating their children and so this
story is is much older than we think and
the fears that we have about vaccines
are or not that's a similar to what
people worried about in the past as well
but Jenner is an incredible figure that
is incredible when you stop and think
about the fact that this is still going
on
today with the internet yeah yeah all
the mean you can find out I mean I had
dr. Peter Hotez on recently to talk
about vaccines and
the misconceptions that people have and
he explained that they've isolated a
bunch of different environmental factors
that and genes that contribute to autism
but that it all takes place in the womb
right people don't want to hear that no
I mean and that is the danger of the way
information is now spread of course echo
chambers it is you know it's
confirmation bias is the real danger
wasn't it was actually harder to get
that message out but a lot of you know
you get famous sort of cartoons of of
people sort of turning the cows or the
cartoonists my new husband is
cartoonists and so it's like that's this
way of this powerful way of kind of
conveying images and fears and stuff and
um so yeah people people had that fear
of vaccines for a long time but Edward
Jenner coming up with his vaccine
undoubtedly saved millions of people's
lives undoubtedly yeah it's just so it's
so amazing that that the problem is
still around today we even with all the
information that we have available yeah
I think you know there was um a Fox News
newscaster who recently said that he
doesn't wash his hands because he can't
see germs I don't know who what he was
joking hopefully you said the next day
he actually washes his hands so so
people were sending that to me because
again like this shirt right and and I I
always tell people you know it is that
idea of what you can't see it's hard to
convince people and with Lister you know
if you think about it here's this young
guy and he's coming along he's saying
there's these invisible little creatures
and they're killing your patients and
trust me
I have this really weird instrument
called a microscope and I can see them
and it was a leap of faith
he was also accusing the older surgeons
of inadvertently killing their patients
because if they weren't washing their
hands they were leading to higher
mortality rates so they probably fought
against it as well yeah so there was
there was huge pushback so what Lister
ultimately does is he turns to the
younger generation and he changes their
minds and so it's a slow burn it's not
like you know the movie moment
unfortunately where it just happens all
in once and it takes quite a long time
on and it's it's weird that it takes so
long because if you think about him
coming in 1876 to America it's after the
Civil War people were dying soldiers
were dying of high infection rates they
were packed
wounds with mud I mean they couldn't get
worse than that right and so people were
dying of all the all these kinds of
infections he comes to Philadelphia to
convince the medical community and
speaker after speaker just denounces him
on the first day and then he gets up and
he does his demonstrations and he starts
to slowly change people's minds but it
takes a long time the the cover of the
of the American Book is on the American
version I should say is a famous
painting by of people and see that by
Samuel gross it's called the gross
clinic um the guy in the middle
it is gross as well but the guy in the
middle of Samuel gross and he so didn't
believe in Lister that he would walk
into the room and he'd slam the door and
he'd say there mr. Lister's germs can't
get in anymore and you can see in this
that he's sticky he's wearing his street
clothes he's sticking his dirty fingers
into this wound and there's a woman in
the background and she's um covering her
face and she's the mother of the patient
and she's wearing black because she
expects her son to die so so this is the
u.s. cover and for the UK cover I think
I sent that to you Jamie
um it's I sent you a picture of both
covers side by side it's another
painting by Eakins and it was done
within ten years and it's called the
Agnew clinic and it's totally different
because the doctors are wearing white
there's a sense that they understand
germs there's a sense that antisepsis is
being used there so that kind of
before-and-after shot in such a short
period that Lister is able to change the
world